Let's go next to our caller from the 5 1 3
area code who's calling today from 5:23.
This is John from Ohio.
Hey, John, what's up?
So we only just started getting some recognition
of terror, Reed.
Sorry.
Look, in the mainstream media, but it still
isn't getting the attention that I think it
should get.
Give a take on why that is or you have to
take her opinion on the issue in general.
Well, listen.
I mean, my view has always been that people
who who come forward and say this happened
to me should be heard and their claims should
be taken seriously and investigated.
And that's my view, regardless of who's being
accused of political or or political party.
Full stop.
Right.
I mean, that that's my view.
And then, you know, there should be a full
and proper investigation in terms of why it's
not getting more coverage in corporate media.
I have two ideas about that.
One is that there is skepticism among some
in corporate media about elements of the story.
Now, I'm not an expert on the story.
So it would sort of be beyond me to go through
all of those details now just on the basis
of your phone call.
You know, I'm not not prepared to do that
right now, nor nor do I think that it's necessarily
the best thing to be doing.
But I think part of what's holding down coverage
in corporate media is skepticism of some elements
of the story.
And whether that's right or wrong is a real
debate to be had.
Right.
I mean, if you believe that accusers allegations
should be taken seriously, then, you know,
take them seriously and and investigate.
And then I think the second thing is also
we're just in a crazy situation with coronavirus
constantly.
And a lot of stories that would normally get
more attention, you know, stuff stuff related
to insane government corruption that would
normally at least make more of a blip.
The terror reed story arguably is part of
that.
You know, some recent thing that's being widely
misinterpreted about UFOs.
But still, it's there's a lot of stories that
I think were it not for coronavirus, would
be getting a lot more attention.
OK.
That's all I wanted to know.
All right, my friend.
Thank you.
Great to hear from you.
Very much.
Appreciate it.